[Musique]
jean montfort bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat au diamant vous avez 64 ans
vous êtes la tête de liste de force
diamantinoise et vous êtes conseiller
municipal de l'opposition
alors si c'est bien ça c'est bien cela
alors parce qu'il pouvait vous présenter
pour nos auditeurs qui ne vous
connaissent pas
quel est votre parcours politique alors
donc tout d'abord je vais faire une
présentation à peine de ce que j'ai déjà
fait d'un mât minogue était
effectivement
je suis proviseur c'est toujours
proviseur vous aviez un établissement
public local d'enseignement de formation
cenal agricole j'ai joué dans plusieurs
établissements martinique
en plus j'ai aussi en guadeloupe donc il
est mené la chose publique me connais
pas ce que j'ai déjà mené plusieurs
expériences dans la cadre du plan de
redressement aussi bien en martinique en
guadeloupe pour adresser des
établissements donc je suis en parfaite
harmonie avec moi-même powe a dressé la
commune du diamant parce que comme vous
savez la guardia mans selon la
difficulté on va on va on va en parler
pourquoi vous vous présentiez alors
présentant jeudi pourquoi nous nous
présentons faut dire martinoise
au diamant pour la simple raison que
nous sommes dans l'opposition ça fait
depuis 2008
nous menons combat au diamant donc c'est
tout naturel que nous nous sommes
présentés aux élections parce que si on
ne se présente pas à l'élection dont on
connaissait la place vide à deux
candidats qui faussent avons et à deux
candidats présents celui du côté du
mairie et celui de
du côté de lyon lâche donc ces deux
candidats ils étaient ensemble jusqu'à
2017 il était en somme donc je ne vois
pas beaucoup de raisons que nous au
niveau de l'opposition
on se serait pas présenté à l'élection
du diamant parce que c'est nous qui vous
représentant l'opposition du diamant je
dirais c'est net c'est possible vous
êtes soutenu par un autre parti
à l'heure actuelle nous ne sommes pas
soutenus par des trois partis nous
sommes sans étiquette nous rassemblant
l'ensemble des diamants chinois parce
que c'est important de le dire
nous rassemblons la somme des diamants
tinois de tout bord politique que ce
soit go soit tous bords politiques donc
pour le moment nous n'avons pas de
soutien de partis même si je sais qu'il
ya des gens qui ont du gène tet2 pia
donc je suis pas plus de tant de ce pays
à demi moore autres donc je suis un
homme de gauche je vais pardon même
cachée celle d'un homme de gauche mais
je travaille avec l'ensemble des
partenaires qui veulent travailler avec
nous au diamant vous disiez tout à
l'heure que qu'il n'y avait pas quelques
vous représentiez le l'opposition il n'y
a pas eu de possibilité par exemple de
faire liste commune avec monsieur tout
s'est alors pour bien vous répondre à la
question posée
nous sommes un moment donné nous sommes
[Musique]
je vais pas
matthew pour la pub diamantine moi nous
sommes rencontrés mais il faut savoir
que nous avons fait de nos 20 personnes
avec nous il faut une fois l'écouté tout
à chacun il faudra borg
comme nous sommes dans l'opposition
depuis 2002 en diamants les
diamantinoise a dit non non non il faut
venir d'élections premier tour monfils
et au deuxième tour on verra charge
alors nous avons rencontré effectivement
changé l'équipe i et ii de biya nous
aller les catalans de pia même si l'élu
du mime et aux dernières escales dire
les du même les degrés d'hugo sable et
non mais il est venu nous voir
effectivement il est gelé rencontrer et
lui souhaite
il souhaite se présentait donc je lui ai
dit s'il souhaite se présenter ça lui
d'aller donc maintenant on avait démarré
plus vite que la porte non non la porte
n'est pas fermée gt on s'est rencontrés
on a discuté
mais bon je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails lui il avait des ambitions
autres donc je lui dis donc ça à lui de
se présenter dans ce cas là c'est lui
qui voit sa fausse et il se présente
sous l'eau ou se représente pas alors
quelles sont les grandes lignes de votre
programme
nous ce que nous voulons au diamant
c'est il faut se dire mais tu es noir et
les possibles en la nécessité d'apporter
au niveau communal d'aidé pour ceux des
réponses adaptées aux problématiques de
la crise sociale actuelle parce que nous
sommes dans une crise sociale il faut
savoir aussi bien économique culturel et
écologique
donc nous nous inscrivons dont le set à
sens et aussi envie de moi mon talent
parce que lorsqu'on parle de problèmes
de cordes et comme j'ai l'habitude de
dire ou diamant nous avons la chance
d'avoir un territoire qui n'est pas
abordée ghosn est donc l'objectif de
défaut d'y remonter noise c'est de
développer des aspects positifs de cette
non contamination des terres de colomb
au diamant pour qu'on puisse développer
l'agriculture et surtout faire des
retenues collinaires blues et reggae le
diamant jean montfort joffre remercie